hello freak [ __ ] that was a good
little joint
I remember Ralphie may rest in peace we
were supposed to meet Ralphie there and
Ralphie showed up an hour later I'm like
what the [ __ ] Ralphie
look in the back seat and he had like 13
boxes those jalapeno poppers from
jack-in-the-box oh my god had gone off
on jalapeno poppers poor Ralphie
when he he had his stomach stapled and
when he had a stomach stapled for some
reason he couldn't eat meat like this
there's something about the operation
they did it made him have a real issue
with meat but he still loved to cook it
so used to barbecue we went over his
house once and he he's a [ __ ] killer
cook yeah Ralphie make his own garlic
you sauce baby big baby barbecue sauce I
want this house and he cooked like this
whole thing and got my boys eating meat
at the time oh yeah he got his staples
removed I mean he did himself just ate
right through those staples yeah he had
this idea that he was gonna lose all
this weight and and and it did kind of
work for like a couple days well the
problem was he was so big that like if
he said he lost weight like you like
okay how much you know he'd say you lost
100 pounds and you'd be like um about I
believe yeah it's hard to tell you know
it's like you couldn't but imagine like
how strong his legs must have been oh
they're the strongest feet in the
business like that guy could probably
kick through a [ __ ] building you
think about it like if he if he's
carrying around 500 pounds imagine if I
took you and I through 300 pounds of
weights on your back you you're just
walking around with 300 pounds
everywhere you go I wouldn't be able to
do it like I lift weights all the time
and I wouldn't be able to do it I'd be
like what the [ __ ] man he would walk
everywhere Buster walls giving us
kool-aid he had those calves
you know those fat dude calves they did
develop this month I bet if you could
like look at the musculature in his legs
I bet if you get through all the fat in
his arms his arms like normal size arms
but I bet he had some jacked [ __ ] Lee
Haney quads yeah I would imagine
[Applause]
[Music]